avec un certain nombre de contacts j'ai
pu obtenir les prix alors est ce qu'ils
font ça tf1 parce que il faut pas
rentrer assez d'argent avec leur pub et
que parce que ça a été compliqué avec la
crise sanitaire et qu'en plus ça permet
à leurs animateurs sert il ya plus de
maintenant de contrat d'exclusivité
oui comme il avait avant les animateurs
ou y toucher par an un contrat
d'exclusivité comme vous aviez benjamin
castaldi ou touché combien par an
j'avais sept cent mille euros par an
quoi pour rien faire ouais bah c'est
dingue et c'est ici vous toucher ses 700
euros ça rentre rien faire alors sept
cent mille euros pour rien faire non
arrêtée par an 70000 euros par mois à
peu près de 50000 euros par mois non
mais jouer je vois et vous et vous
donner en plus
après j'essaie mais elle après sa soeur
bien sûr vous avez vous gagné combien de
gars comme on dit fait et on peut
tourner à combien par an 2 millions je
vous le dis déjà pour autant un million
et demi de millions par an et 2 millions
par an
mais je crois que c'est fini c'est plus
le cas maintenant aujourd'hui dont je
n'ai plus de millions voire en on ne
sont pas les autres animateurs de tf1
non mais écoutez je sais pas quels sont
les contrats je sais que l'aîné prime et
tout ça se négocie toujours au même
tarif que le mien hors taxes s'est tous
à peu près la même chose
après ce sont les primes d'exclure ceux
qui en avaient d'avant les ont gardés
mais les nouveaux entrants les ne les
ont plus mais juste pour dire ça c'est
assez
c'est plutôt malin la part de teva parce
qu'avant moi à mon époque n'avait pas
d'argent ce qui nous représentait et il
est long nous venez nous voir parce
qu'on était à tf1 et que c'était
évidemment une marque doit la marque
importante tf1 je veux voir d'abord les
deux qui sont choqués et le lauréat est
très sympa mais voilà guy aujourd'hui
moi je fais ça honteux qu'une chaîne qui
fait les centaines de millions d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires se gavent sur des
prestations de leurs animateurs qui
n'ont rien à voir avec leur émission en
plus est pour des entreprises privées
comme vous l'avez dit cyril ya plus de
contrats d'exclure jour d'hui donc oui à
des animateurs qui travaille très
souvent qu'il ya très bien en vie mais
aussi des animateurs dans le groupe tf1
qui font rien donc ils n'ont pas d'exclu
on leur demande d'attendre là gentiment
leur seule manière de gagner leur vie
c'est en faisant des ménages et ils
viennent se gaver de ne prendre à
prendre 10% devant 30 millions
franchement c'est n'importe quoi
on